[Music]
all right so we all understand
that uh when you post on instagram we
usually most of us
and i'm looking at you steve because you
don't play this game but most of us like
to post
very flattering photos of ourselves i
don't do that
feel attacked right now you feel you
feel intense he posts the most
flattering what
the [ __ ] are you talking about i use
filters the most flattering photo he's
ever posted
yeah i don't that's pretty i don't post
it oh yeah no filters are you kidding me
i don't post no hold on
wait no filter is a favorite serious
side note no filter is a flex
yeah but he he only posts a filter are
you serious dude i've never i don't even
know what a filter is a lot of shopping
what the [ __ ] are you talking about your
rosy cheeks that is so no
honestly my lawyer is going to be
talking to you because that's really
bring it
no and that's slander that's steve's
natural skin
have you not seen in person
he matches that donut in the back
but yeah let's let's uh i had to look at
the donut and i went oh
oh this is glazed you look so glazed
yeah
glass people say i look very glazed
which i i think is a compliment it you
should
it's a it's a glow it's a blaze glow
okay strawberry glaze
dude dude nikki glaze nicky pretty good
that's a backup [ __ ] my name yo
nikki bangs nikki glaze and all of them
just
keep sounding poor normally kind of my
glaze is pretty bad glue
glaze is very donut-y i thought i
thought it was like it's very
comfy yeah oh i didn't even think of
that yeah
oh my god i had no idea that's horrific
i know terrific we shall not use that
we got to take the name blaze back guys
yeah but yeah so back to uh showing off
our best selves and our in our and our
lavish lifestyles my lavish lifestyle
like lavish
live like and i use live very loosely
here
uh that we've posted oh for me i
i had a big pot and i was uh drinking
from a ladle
which nothing was there but i use that
as a point to tell people
look don't believe everything that you
believe that you see don't believe me
don't believe what you see on social
media i don't i'm not drinking
[ __ ] right now see i do that all the
time man i expose
so people know i love how it just hit it
next level like
man it's all a conspiracy man
posted
because really it would be super hot i
would never put it into my lips
where are you trying to get it uh well
i'm just trying to get out because i'm
just like no no i ain't standing on the
ground like that it's real life
it's real life exactly and all the
happiness and all the
perfect wardrobe and hair is first off
if you catch my instagram stories you
know that'll lie i'll be showing up with
no makeup so we don't end up like these
people
true so a number of popular tik tok and
instagram influencers have been exposed
for how ugly they are i hope it's that
yeah i like that they're not tens
actually
there is a whole subreddit page called
uh instagram versus reality or something
like that
where they're posting photos of people
that have
very clearly photoshopped and then they
post the original
and then you can compare have you seen
the prawn stars without the makeups
yeah the prawn stars dude the prom
there's a they
have a before and after yeah after they
make up it's porn star so gotcha now say
it again i like how it's
like some some kind of tricks being
pulled on yeah i'm not quite sure what
you or you could realize that your
standards are actually very low and
that makes there's so many beautiful
girls out there joe she has a toe that's
like this much bigger than the other one
and like she's ugly
okay like shallow health yeah yeah
that's true but yeah so a number of
instagramers and uh just influencers in
general
have been exposed for faking their
luxurious lifestyles by
renting a los angeles studio designed to
look like the inside of a private
all those jet jet rides and all broke
hoes
ain't [ __ ] busted fake and for the price
of what
65 dollars an hour that's a good point
that's a good price thousand dollars
ever created it you'll get your bread
that person
is brilliant yeah where did they say
they were going
to ask spence let me let me let me let
me show you guys turning all social
media off for like a [ __ ] week [ __ ]
we're going to like the barbados
well you just wanted to disconnect plane
because i feel like you could get one
for like a grand
no versus 65 dollars an hour and all now
you have one photo
it doesn't take that long to get a phone
one photo hold on to running a private
plane is about at least 24 000 one way
depending on where twenty four thousand
yeah
the whole planet oh yeah i thought it
was a couple grand no
no no no i didn't know i didn't know i
didn't know it was that cheap because
jetsweet is
a well that's like an uber no it's about
like 24 to 48 depending on where you're
going
wow yeah because think about how much
does jet suite cost go like a couple
hundred dollars each person
i could get a propeller plane for a
hundred bucks an hour
how about that it's a three seater and
you haven't taken me up there yet what
the [ __ ] you bragging for
oh i'm scared because you know why i
want i'm i'm worried about your safety
and i don't want you to die because the
pilot is someone who just got his
license listen if you go and take
another [ __ ] on that and you sent on
instagram i'm coming for you
i'm not going to take another [ __ ] on
damn right the only kind of [ __ ] i'm
around are men
and we take it as a compliment amen
amen y'all wanted this relationship to
happen well guess what
and boys that's how you get out of
trouble
all right so we're going next week yup
but yeah here's a photo
it looks fake actually come on it
doesn't look like lazy boy recliner is
about to be
i don't think they're trying to dress it
up you know what i actually wish you
didn't tell me
because i i would love to judge this
with fresh eyes but i do think this
looks fake though okay i try to i know
the information i just told you no i
know
it's because they do it in close-ups
right you're not i think that
when you're sitting from here to here
with the windows it's legit yeah look at
that i just think there's no utility
with you just create a picture in that
direction
i think all they're going for is that
like window mm-hmm and then the
background right
yeah it'll look pretty decent yeah these
are the peer space photos if
you don't know what peer space is it's a
website to rent out uh
venues and things for events or photo
shoots or film shoots
so basically it wasn't meant for
instagrammers right
how is that that looks real so this was
meant for like
like people booking for filming or
something yes so
so i think what people don't realize and
this is three's on a plane
right and the reason why i think this
went viral is because i don't think
people realize in l.a
we are surrounded by studios and photo
places and video places to rent that you
can
you know recreate things like that i
hate can we all look at this girl's hair
and look at my hair
oh [ __ ] hey what are you doing in here
can we look at it
you know what you know what i love can
we focus on what i love her face says
like i'm not really on a private jet
okay are we ready are we ready oh you
need the arm
yeah the other arm you need to look
internally saturn
internally sad though internally set
there we go thank you thank you
perfect and then we just gotta rotoscope
you and put you here yeah
lift your chin a little hey hey a little
more i'm a fraud
oh there it is yeah yeah yeah that was
it that was it
great great you pulled it off what a
good model yeah how do you question me
yeah there's another one she's
completely oh dude she's like i'm
literally asleep
because i'm on a private jet i this is
her
champagne life another day i want to
know what they think
absolutely i don't know they protected
their their instagrams
i don't know yeah she's like oh another
day of this
tough life my mom is forcing me to go to
my audition today
my i mean we're so in love he's flying
me out
she's like my casting director is going
to beat my [ __ ] up
oh i can't wait this is our just another
date
just another day this one it's always
it's like the
the ah yeah you know that pose though
i'm like oh my god my life's so hard
because it's so dope oh my gosh
and here's one of the tips there's a
video yes here we go
stop yes stop yes spain
what you doing hey reporting live it's
trap bunny bubbles
i want to live in that mansion big house
playboy buddy what's happening here
having their pedal to the metal i'm
gassing vroom
timers on my neck and they're dancing ah
bad little baby what's cracking what's
cracking
what is that just a tick tock of them
using that space oh my god
oh there we go there we go here it is
all right do you know this song
yes i do here we go whoa
it's like a mirror yeah it looks just
like her
yeah because they all have similar hair
too
no seriously you have to pay the bill
here you go
it's been an hour your time is up yeah
you need to leave couldn't you have just
waited for us to cut it
so tick tock video sorry i don't know
how it works i see the camera my
channels
are rented too these [ __ ] have to go
back as well oh [ __ ]
okay and the truck all the wardrobe
every time everything
even your friends are renting your
expression is rented yeah expression has
to be returned
pure fact that i know that song is
terrible why would song
no any of the songs because i'd be on
the ticket to talk every once while i
would be so
judgmental if i was a part of that pure
space like
property really i would be looking at
people every single person i'm like
you are a faker please please i would
judge if it's
if it's for their personal social media
to pretend like they're going somewhere
then [ __ ] i'm judging hard but then
if it's like a photo shoot or some other
[ __ ]
yeah the tick tock thing is not so bad i
feel like no the tick tock thing is
[ __ ] trash because they are
advertising to a
bunch of little people who think that
they are balling out
that that is the life that they live and
it's not as a baller movie
mogul which i am uh
i didn't say it you guys did and uh i
just want to point out
there's always a butler on these flights
i'm always on these flights there's
always a [ __ ] butler
so you need a butler to proof right
there's no butler
that's not real that's what that means i
feel like i
so easy even if i could afford it i
wouldn't do it classes change
what private private yeah i wouldn't do
it i would rather be in a propeller
plane
i hear you bro but yeah i don't know but
i don't know i
i i i feel for them too because i'm like
i mean
it's their business you know it's like
it's you're so what's your love one
thing it's lifestyles
but it's it's your career if you make
money doing this
how do i look like i'm on a private jet
but i'm not i have more respect for the
person that
put up the ipad have you seen the one
where they take the ipad and then they
have the little
uh laundry basket and they pretend that
they're in a plane and they have like
something flying oh that's
smart i like that you all cashed out
y'all broke hoes
all right all right okay you changed my
mind you're only creative once they
actually reveal it though
and it's funny this is some girl trying
to get caught up by a sugar daddy y'all
changed my mind
[Music]